[Music]
hello everyone this is women's Grand
Master Sabina for sure and I'm here at
the San Luis chess club and we have kids
well Knights the nice class right so for
today I've decided to prepare some of my
own games and I will not be showing you
all of my games but I'll be showing you
some of the blunders that I made and
some of the things that I missed as well
I think that maybe I didn't Miska
sometimes you know you don't want to
just show your bed stuff you want to
show some nice things as well so
hopefully you'll enjoy them and you'll
be able to find things that I missed
it's tough sometimes as a chess player
to to show your losses but I want to
show you today that it's a process
you're going to make mistakes sometimes
but if you learn from them you're going
to get to become stronger and get better
right and get to to do them maybe to do
similar things in your own games as well
so this is the first the first game that
the first position that I have for you
and actually I had black here and uh
what do you think about this position
who is better white is better why is
that
but this is still an opening position
right so it's not this bad for black but
certainly it's quite it has white has
some some pluses right we have the
central pawns blacks better know like is
not better but this was Kim anyone tell
me what was the opening of this Slav but
there is a bishop in G no no it wasn't
how can it before nice for next to see
forty five right black has a pawn black
has upon innocence Queen's Gambit your
clothes but White has a bishop bianchi
added there is a bishop fianchetto gingy
- its coffee and keto Yankee Tom okay in
English is called fianchetto okay so
there's a bishop in G - so we have a
Catalan anyone heard about the opening
called Catalan good okay so that's what
we had and I have made not the best
decision when white pushed this pawn to
e4 I made the wrong move capturing here
and I thought I can equalize the
position by pushing c5 when your
opponent has the center you do not want
to let them have all that Center right
you want to make sure that you can
counter-attack it and your pieces will
do something right now if you look at
blacks pieces this Knight is not doing
so so well in a6
does it no so we need to help it get
into play so I thought c5 was the
natural move here because I'm going to
open my bishop if you take my knight
will come into play and I was quite
happy about the situation unfortunately
I missed a very simple tactics what did
I miss here what did my opponent do
try to think about what the ideas
they're present in this position yes
what do you mean like what is my threat
we see five okay let's let's do that
first yes Bishop takes e4 Knight takes
e4 I'm attacking this Knight - right so
let's try to think what white might want
to consider doing about this Knight yes
Knight takes Knight okay that's quite
good you get rid your knight from from
the attack and now I have two choices
right they can take with the bishop or
with the pawn in the game I took with
the bishop with the pawn so what can I
do here
if I had taken with the pawn someone who
didn't say anything yes bishop where h6
rook e8
yes I know and I played okay so you play
Bishop h6 and now what
okay so let's find another good move for
white here yes
Queenie for Oh be careful I have a
bishop yes 95 interesting what is the
threat of this move checkmate right but
also we discover our Bishop to b7 so
when black is going to take here our
next move will be Bishop takes b7 we
have sacrificed a knight cut or Bishop
back and now we have this fork so why
does black do he has this intermediate
move right what do we do now with white
yes Queenie four rwby eight yes takes on
c5 and we'll have a pretty pretty great
position with white in the game I just I
realized what mistake I made and I
thought at least I'll not weaken my King
so I took with the bishop but of course
the exact same idea happened to me so
I've always feared of sacrifices in h7
here we do not have a sacrifice right we
do not have the Greek gift but we have a
similar idea to the great gift that that
utilizes two separate ideas and just
because you have a nineteen f6 that
protects your King doesn't mean your
role is safe as you can see here I don't
have the knight now I have the bishop I
should be totally fine but because I
misplace my pieces here and I made the
mistake of actually allowing the
diagonal to be open I ended up just
losing this game I mean I kept playing
but obviously after Bishop takes g5
Bishop takes d7 this intermediate move
Queen b3 and now takes White has a big
advantage and of course eventually led
to me losing the game okay so you saw my
first tough loss and this wasn't a
really long time ago it was quite recent
so let's see another game another game
that I missed something in so basically
here I had white and and I played in
this position rook to f1 let's try to
understand what's happening in this
position and find blacks blessed the
best move who is better here
yes why is black better yes the king is
in the corner and black has an extra
pawn I do have maybe some compensation
because his King is not doing so great
either but if I don't manage to actually
attack it it's not so good right
additionally Black has all of these
pieces on the F file so that could give
him some important tactical ideas what
could black do here to make his win very
easy
it's a line I mean I mean you want what
do you want to do move the night well
where do you move the night your queen
is attacked right yes
night xg3 okay what do I do it White
Queen takes or pond takes I only have
two choices
let's check Queen first what do we do
now
Quinn takes f1 rook takes okay and
nothing who is that it was winning now
white is winning because even if you
give me rook F to check and you think
I'm going to yeah to go here and then
you'll win my queen no no I will take
and now I'm the one who stays with extra
material look sometimes you have to
still keep some pieces to win the game
right you cannot sacrifice all of them
so obviously you're not going to
sacrifice your queen you take here right
trade the Queen's first I need to take
back with the pawn right if I take rook
takes f6 what's happening which one no
we take this one right our queen is
attacked right in this position white
attacks both the rock in f8 and the
Queen in g3 so you take you get rid of
the Queen from the attack and then yeah
so of course white has to take and now
what do we do
just grab the rook and in this position
black was able to trade all the pieces
get into a rock n game with two extra
pawns and black should be able to win
right
my opponent missed this he he played
something else and eventually still won
but I just thought it's a nice position
to show anyways I ended up losing I had
black I had white this was kind of a
painful loss for me this next position
that I will be showing you I was playing
in the Olympiad representing the u.s. in
2014 and I had this moment 5 out of 5 I
won 5 of 5 games and we were playing
against France and I had a very good
game
I was I was better and then suddenly I
started forgetting about my pieces and
what do you think about this position
who would you say is better here black
is better why is black better in this
position yes excuse me okay you're
changing just tell me the reason it can
be either one I I don't mind but I need
to hear a reason why one of the sides is
better what do we look at to figure out
whether white is better or black is
better yes count pieces aha blacks
pieces are all kind of on backs a badly
placed on back and the back rank yes
what else did you say they don't seem to
be doing so much okay yes black poem
before spinned very nice to see that
idea I was aware of that what else I am
white in this position
what pawn a3 interesting that's an
interesting move here yeah it's quite an
interesting move what is black threat in
this position yes
no he doesn't want to take my knight
because as someone mentioned here right
that pawn is pinned right so that point
cannot take my knight but but that is an
idea
that is an idea the black has to keep in
mind and I have to keep in mind too
because I left my knight hanging there
right what is black threat in this
position which I missed I did not look
for threats
so hopefully this lesson will be good
for you because you will learn from me
and you will look for your opponent
stretch yes Bishop a5 b5 what's the idea
it's an interesting move but the thing
is my knight can capture it if I want to
write and then I get rid with my knife
from the attack and everything is fine
the idea that black has in this position
which I miss yes no I mean okay that's
that's an idea
certainly yeah but also anyone else has
any idea before I show this which one
take the rope the pawn in d6 yes is 97
black's idea and threat here is 97 which
a completely missed there's a tactical
idea presence so what they are doing
with 97 is not only they attack my
bishop they also protect the rock in b8
which means just because they move the
knight it doesn't mean they only have a
threat with the night because the knight
protects the rook what is their threat
besides the bishop yes B takes c3 so
basically in this position I ended up
playing rook e to d1
I thought I'm protecting my pawn in d6
because I thought that's the threat and
that's you know strong piece that I have
in the position I do not want to lose it
all my pieces are placed greatly or at
least I thought so but they are not
really just because your pieces look
passive it doesn't mean that you cannot
have threats and that's what my opponent
showed me as soon as you play 97 what
can I do I'm going to lose a piece
hmm no I ended up playing Marcus I
couldn't I couldn't get myself to
resigning also when you play in a team
you don't really want to lose too fast
because then your teammates will be
feeling like they have to win and and
it's it's kind of tough for the match I
ended up playing more but eventually
unfortunately I ended up losing because
I'm losing a piece there's nothing that
I can do about it one of these two
pieces will be lost so make sure that
you you when you see a position you
evaluate it and even if it's seems worse
for you don't immediately think that
okay you know it's over no it's it's
never over okay now as you can see I've
prepared a lot of losses because I
really think it's I lost this one to the
song so okay I'm I'm not afraid of
sharing my losses because I've learned a
lot of ideas and I think a lot of us are
often scared to share our losses and
then we just punish ourselves too much
you know if you are ready to go over
your losses you're already showing signs
of improvement so in this position who
do you think is better
what is better why is that a pair of
bishop and what else
excuse me black right okay I never heard
that expression okay you see a tactic
what is it
rook takes B 8 and then 96
well if Luke takes b8 I'm forced to take
with one of my rooks so which one of the
rooks am I going to take back with the
Rock'em before so you don't have that
fork okay
so in this position I thought I'm going
to try to escape this difficult position
of my 19 b8 as you all kind of pointed
out my nating b8 is not doing so great
right I'm a little bit passable with
that night and I thought I was ready to
improve its position and instead of
considering maybe like trying to capture
here right I mean it's not so good to
give up your your pair of bishops but
the position is is close so the White
has the pair of bishops is not as bad
for me instead I thought I can just
trade my Knights what did I miss
let's give everyone a little bit of time
to think about this
hmm what seems to be the problem of
blacks position a lot of pieces are
hanging right this looking before this
there's a discovery here right there's a
pin here yes who wanted to say something
yes yes Knight takes D seven okay and
the idea is okay yes Bishop where g5
interesting interesting can i play Queen
c7 or maybe Bishop e7
so why don't you play 96 immediately why
don't you play night II 6 immediately
you said 96 hours a night a 6
look at look at this move Knight d6
this is
what's happening why am i giving up a
piece with white what's the future of
this the reason of this sacrifice yes so
what does why do here yes
Quinn takes c6 protects the Ragini eight
which was my idea I thought 97 right is
going to attack the rogue I will trade
the rook and then I'll be fine I'm
trading an active piece of whites but
unfortunately now I've just lost the
pawn and guess what the rook is still
there he's still attacking me and it's
with tempo so okay I ended up playing
out to be more but eventually lost here
this was a game that I played quite
poorly actually and finally I was able
to get some however of a safe position
until I missed the tactical idea and you
guys found it so well done okay finally
let's see one game that I actually want
okay so yay I actually won again I mean
obviously I've tried to choose more
losses because I wanted this lesson
today too to give you some confidence
that just because you lose you don't
need to give up chess or you need to
feel bad on yourself or whatever okay
already so who is better in this
position black huh why is that
[Music]
really
don't they have with white and extra
pawn how do we evaluate the position
okay let's see this this is important
you cannot just base your judgment on
some random facts seriously so we need
to base our judgment on the position on
the things that are happening on the
board was the first thing we're looking
at in a position no no no no being
safety King safety which of the two
kings is safer
maybe maybe black safer but White's King
is totally fine too I mean how will you
bring your pieces to attack me right
he's not being attacked I have a lot of
pawns pushed indeed but there's no piece
that can reach my King anytime soon okay
then what's the second thing we're
looking at material so it seems like I'm
doing better here with white no okay
what's the next thing we're doing we're
looking at pawn structure
okay let's look at pawn structure whose
pawn structure is better blacks why
what okay so let's let's discuss
something when you look at pawn
structure what are the important things
that you should consider because pawn
structure is too broad we need to narrow
it down on some subsections yes pawn
islands I would say the first thing you
should look at is center and space first
in my opinion because especially if the
position is closed or if you have the
center those are the first things that
pop up in your mind should pop up first
so in this case it seems like white has
more space don't you think I mean these
pawns are more advanced they are
restricting you right and then yes after
that you look at pawn islands and I
agree with you I do have some points
here F 3 F 5 H 3 that are isolated and
potentially weak but you also have to
attack them right which pieces of yours
are going to attack my weaknesses the
Queen only the Queen only right and I'm
well protected
okay so pawn structure yes I do have
some weaknesses but they are not easily
attackable by blacks pieces also I have
more space okay and I have a majority on
the Queen side too although it looks
blockaded for now just imagine an
endgame if I push some b4 b5 right in an
endgame King opponent game you will take
with one of your pawns and then I will
have a passed pawn that's an interesting
idea to keep in mind anyways
so after we look at the pawn structure
what else do we look at yes
you can look at development yes what
else yes
one of you what space and that was part
of the pawn structure right center space
like pawn structure you look at center
space weaknesses and weak weak squares -
you can you can add there as well
yes material we looked at second thing
yes yes placement of pieces good well
placed pieces and you can also look at
pair of bishops if you have the pair of
bishops then of course you can look at
that as well and that can be a plus if
the position is open or maybe a minus or
useless if the position is located but
here we don't have that so placement of
pieces okay whose pieces are better
placed in this position yes White's
pieces I mean I have a knight here this
doesn't do so much for this reason it's
an outpost unfortunately doesn't do as
much though I have to agree doesn't do
as much but it might be helpful you see
in a second I have my rook on the file I
have Queen quite okay what are how our
blacks piece is doing this bishop is
somewhat trapped for the moment this
rook as well so what do I do in this
position with why do I have any pieces
that are not placed so well yes you know
one of you yeah
the bishop okay so what do I do
my opponent play queen g3 here like you
guys were telling me I have weaknesses
he thought he can go and attack them
he played queen g3 here what did I do
yes Bishop h2 he took the pawn why to
move yes okay
okay Brooke h2 trapping the Queen right
now you can see why that pawn in h3 was
not so weak I attracted his queen to go
there and then I just wanted quite
easily right if he didn't do this
of course I wouldn't have won so easily
but I took care of my pieces I try to
improve the position of my best shop and
attracted him to go for a random pawn
which ended up trapping his Queen was
this nice not as nice as those games I
lost though right okay
now this is another game that I want is
quite quite nice okay so let's try to
evaluate this this position I have black
and it's white to move here but first we
evaluate the position and then we'll see
what has happened black is much better
it's about equal this position is about
equal I mean I have some attack on the
King's on the Queen side but my opponent
also has some piece is active there and
in this position we were both in time
trouble and this was played the u.s.
championship years ago and my opponent
played the following move she was in
time trouble she barely had any time and
she thought she's going to attack my
weakness here in e6
what did she miss
it's not the check man think about it
what has happened when the move and when
the bishop moved from C to yes the night
is still defended by the bishop right
oh no no no she's putting she's
attacking here but she's not going to
take it immediately she maybe wants to
trade the Queen's first and then take
the pawn yes
rook c1 yes check it it was very tough
so after that of course I'm winning so
back rank can be a big issue not only
when you're mating but sometimes you can
win some material as well okay this game
I want as well yeah I have to win I have
to show some winning games too right or
else you guys will think I'm just losing
everything why am i teaching you here
right okay I am white in this position
and I want you to take a look at the
position and try to understand who is
better here it's we have a queen and
rook and game and who is better
yes wife has some attack on the kingside
and white species are more active than
blacks also they look coordinated a
little bit the Queen and the rook are
kind of looking together a blacks King
where is blacks Queen for the moment is
still stuck over here right and this the
Queen and the rook they don't attack
together they are just for the moment
really uncoordinated I like to call it
yes I have some ideas like that I
started with this check first
my opponent only has one move what is it
King h8 if my power plays King g8 what's
happening I can take in h6 and the fact
that you have you do not have your
pieces coordinated to actually threaten
a mate yeah I mean my King maybe looks
weaker but because of the way the pawns
are placed you don't reach my king you
only have one check here here and then
there might be it right
what do we do now yes Rock G - if you
play root G - can I try to play root
Queen to f6 to offer a queen trade and
defend okay yes Queen f7 interesting
what is your threat with that move
somehow checkmate on g7 but you don't
have a threat right
you cannot play without threats it can
get dangerous if black activates his
queen think about it if you play Queen
f7 maybe I can give you this check Queen
to g5 your queen is away from here right
and suddenly maybe I have some checks
maybe some threats that you cannot
defend yes no no he said that in this
position we play Queen f7 obviously I
would not play Queen g5 myself here
because I I know I'm pinned he said
Queen f7 in this position okay that's
why I said Queen g5 let's make sure of
that okay yes yeah yeah f6 very nice
double exclam move what is my threat
with this move Quinton g7 mate right so
what is what are some of blacks defenses
yes
okay so my opponent can take the pawn
first you should think of that first
right then you should take a think of
some queen here I guess or queen g8
sounds good
he gave me a check here first and now we
let's look in this position at those
moves cos okay it really doesn't matter
if the check is happening or not okay so
let's look at Queen g8 first what do we
do have two Queen g8 yes rook takes h6
Oh
pawn takes h6 no I know pawn takes I
take back Queen takes h6 Queen h7 look
what happened to you check o check and
now I have a counter check you see rook
c4 was there for a reason right softer
Queen here who is winning now black so I
was attacking but I have to be very
careful how I'm continuing these things
because if the Queen goes to g8 oopsie
he might want to play Queen h7 so we
have to be very cautious about that what
do we do here yes 20x g7 okay Queen
takes g7
rook takes h6 check King g8 okay what
does black do after Queenie a check
locate red or blue g6 you can do robbed
g6 - here right well done all okay Jade
and regardless you win the Queen very
good so what about if you play screen f8
I think we don't need to look at this
anymore because it's exactly the same
thing just right F takes G 7 you're
forced to take back and we have the same
so my opponent took with the Queen in
accent yes rook takes h6 very good what
does black do okay once again we are not
trying to go checks around here if you
go there it was just over because now
right yes so why was I winning here
although I had upon down
my pieces were more coordinated and
although my King seemed dangerously
placed without much protection black's
pieces were not coordinated and they
were not able to get me any child into
any checks or threaten any mates I was
first and I also had the help of a pawn
that could completely open up the
position of blacks King good okay it
feels good to see some winning games
right okay let's look at this position
this is more like it takes it takes a
couple of moves to find the winning idea
but let's try to evaluate this position
and see who is better here black is
better in this position are you sure are
you sure black is better but why so now
you learned a new word coordinator so
you're gonna use it all the time right
good good yes so blacks pieces are
looking in the direction of white skin
white skin with these pawns being pushed
is is weak right and black already has
like the night close by the Queen the
rook active right so we have a lot of
pieces looking at blacks King I'm sorry
at White's King so in this position of
course might I had a threat Ryan played
a5 so my opponent took the pawn what
should we do with black in this position
what is our winning idea yes Knight g4
what is your threat with 94 Knight e3
and then if I take you want to checkmate
me in g2 right what about if you play
Knight to g4
what about if I take your queen or your
rook and then when you play this can we
try to find a defense for white not to
get checkmated
no if we take it upon there's a
checkmate so don't forget about your own
King in the process of attacking what
has opened when my night went away from
f6 Queen d6 so in this position white is
able to trade your most important piece
in the attack and then white should be
winning so when you attack just because
your opponent's king is really weak you
shouldn't just think about he about how
you do things you have to think about
some ways that they might have to avoid
the things that you want to do so in
this position right he has a threat your
rook do we need to hurry here with black
is it the type of position that we need
to hurry - checkmate our opponent why
not yes
he's be his position his Kings position
is already weak here wise Kings position
is already weak and he doesn't have
pieces that can come easily to protect
his King because of the pawn structure
because of the placement of pieces most
of his pieces are on the Queen side and
then this one is just going to be
restricting the king from exiting which
anyways it doesn't matter so we do not
need to hurry we have sufficient time to
bring more pieces into the attack yes I
didn't put g7 I brought the rook to e7
and look at those errors that I prepared
for you guys rook to e7 and now what I
mean my arrows already point out too
that the - my idea right
I'm taking my rook from the attack and
I'm slowly bringing it into play and
just I want to bring it to e3 the same
idea as who said it earlier someone the
idea with 94 III just that now we're
bringing the rook with a similar idea to
sacrificing g3 and of course you cannot
take because we'll have to mate
my opponent played here Queen takes d5
look there he came Queen b8 to defend
the threat and obviously I'm very lucky
because my knight controls not I mean
other pieces control - but controls any
potential checks so I'm not really
worried about that and what did I do now
you probably can find more more moves
that win here but
some ideas right I have all the pieces
coordinated right I mean just need a
little bit to have some threads
yeah form to h4f for you mean upon take
sage for interesting that's an
interesting continuation certainly i
choose to make this other move whoopsie
I chose to do this to finish the game a
little bit faster closing the action of
my opponents Queen and now I want to
take in g3 and do not be scared that
you're weakening your king there are no
ways to get to my king right my knight
is an amazing protector of my king and
then my opponent offered the Queen trade
and of course I did trade them right I
traded them no I was hoping to hear a
big no-no of course I didn't trade and
by the way did you see that 19 b3 I
didn't even think of taking it I went
rook takes g3 yeah and then took
checkmate
thanks for watching
[Music]
you
[Music]